[Music]
hi i'm leah cohen the chef owner of pig
and cow and today we're making pork
belly adobo so if you're unfamiliar with
pork belly this is where bacon comes
from which everyone loves bacon and it's
important to get it with a skin on and
you can get it from any local grocery
store and just ask the butcher to
butcher it for you the important thing
is to make sure that you get the bones
removed so we want to leave the skin on
because we really want that nice
contrast of texture and the goal here is
to get the skin really crispy and then
the meat inside is going to be really
nice and tender during the braising
process the meat basically absorbs
whatever flavors you have in the braise
after the pork belly comes out of the
braise we want to cool it
and we want to leave the skin uncovered
the important part is that we are trying
to get rid of all the moisture and we're
trying to dry out the skin and this is
really important for your safety and to
make the skin really crispy
my mom is from the philippines she has a
few dishes that she does really really
well and actually adobo her version was
chicken but adobo was one of the first
filipino dishes she taught me how to
make and i just kind of became obsessed
with food and it just evolved into a
career
as a professional chef
so before we fry the pork belly we're
going to score the top of the skin and
this is really important because this
will help when you slice a pork belly
you're not crushing the skin and you
keep it intact if you pre-score the
belly before you fry it it will make it
easier to cut because the skin will get
really nice and hard which is what we're
trying to achieve but it can also make
it a little more difficult to cut
through at this point the pork belly is
fully cooked and all we're trying to do
is get the outside and the skin really
crispy by deep frying it
my parents actually met in dental school
in the philippines i've been visiting
southeast asia since i was four and a
half years old um that was the first
time i was outside of the us and every
time we would go you know to visit the
family in the philippines my parents
they would take me to another country
like thailand or japan or korea on the
end of the trip because we traveled so
far to get there we might as well tack
on one other country so that's where i
think my obsession for southeast asian
cuisine or asian cuisine in general came
from i opened pagan cow in september of
2012. the name of that means actually
pork and rice so it's great for what
we're making today
this dish is really important to me
because it is a rite of passage every
filipino has their variation of adobo
and everyone thinks that their recipe is
better than the others and this dish was
taught to me by my mom i am
incorporating my love of pork but this
sauce is based off of the sauce that she
taught me how to make as a child oh yes
[Music]
you